you know the gist 13 years in the making
new technology underwater yada yada but
what do the fans have to say about
Avatar the way of water
the second installment in the Avatar
franchise was released internationally
on December 15th and those who rushed
out to see the sequel are now giving
their reviews on Twitter James Cameron
had a lot on his plate with the movie
but the director certainly isn't afraid
of a challenge there is at least one
more sequel on the way after the way of
water and possibly additional Avatar
flicks if everyone is happy with number
two the day we deliver Avatar 2 we'll
just start working on finishing Avatar
3. so are they happy well those lucky
enough to have seen the film already
certainly are so there is a lot to look
forward to from Cameron in the decade
ahead let's get straight to it finding a
negative reaction to Avatar the way of
water is no easy feat as one Twitter
user posted just got out of Avatar the
way of water and wow what a gorgeous
film didn't feel like three hours to me
and I could honestly spend more time
with this family and characters
meanwhile another said Avatar the way of
water did not disappoint epic Graphics
acting storytelling and did the original
Justice loved it some were going so far
as to name Avatar the way of water the
best movie they'd ever seen one tweet
read that movie might just be my
favorite movie of all time the story The
visuals they had a battle in the
beginning middle and end and I loved
every character another moviegoer
compared the Avatar sequel to other
recent underwater flicks and it's clear
one Reigns Supreme they said after
Avatar the way of water I will never
ever watch the first Aquaman again
Aquaman and the way of water aren't even
in the same ballpark so watching the
former again is going to come off as a
major bummer it's hard to find someone
who straight up hated Avatar the way of
water but some people do seem to take
exception to the movies lengthy 192
minute run time as one Twitter user
posted I like the first 45 minutes the
First underwater scene scene in the
movie comes only after that then it
becomes a full-blown documentary on Seas
for like one hour many Twitter users
mentioned that the film was a little too
long in their posts but they often
followed up with a compliment one user
said Avatar the way of water was
incredibly beautiful a long ride but so
worth it another road definitely a
Disney Family story and slightly long
but overall a fun in theater experience
if three hour films aren't a problem for
you of course it seems like you won't
have any complaints about the way of
water one person even claimed you won't
notice the three hour plus run time
writing the three hours doesn't seem
long at all and you don't want it to end
you are constantly at the edge of your
seat nervous it is a movie theater
experience so if you love the first
avatar you should be thrilled with the
way of water I see you
see you
Twitter users have praised everything
from the movie's visuals to its 3D
technology while pointing out that the
story is more complex than the first
movie many pointed out that the movie's
themes and characters were particularly
compelling as one Twitter user said some
pacing issues aside there is a powerful
emotional story about family over the
spectacle the way to return to Pandora
was worth it there were plenty of tweets
praising Zoe Saldana's natiri in
particular which is no surprise given
she's a standout than the original film
Jake and natiri's children also seem to
be a highlight and naturally you should
also be ready to shed some tears one
poster said Avatar the way of water was
a near Perfect movie A stunning visual
James Cameron Masterpiece of a movie
dude knows how to make a sequel my wife
cried 10 times all in all the way of
water appears to be worth the wait and
moviegoers are likely to have one of
their best theater experiences of the
year
[Music]
foreign
[Music]